le deuxième buz du jour c'est cette
vidéo de la militante Juliette brience
qui a énormément fait réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux avec déjà plus de 3
millions de vues ça s'est passé hier
dans le métro parisien sur la ligne 12 à
la station Trinité plusieurs jeunes
écoutaient de la musique avec leurs
haut-parleurs dans la rame dérangeant
plusieurs passagers don Juliette
toujours selon Juliette ces jeunes mett
également leurs pieds sur les sièges
d'en face pour empêcher les gens de
s'asseoir lorsqu'elle a décidé d'agir
tout ne s'est pas passé dans le calme
regardez la scène a été filmée par
Juliette regardez elle sera avec nous
dans un
instant
sonttig il veent pas entendre votre
musique éteigz votre musique soyez
civilis non non fautéteindreteind comme
ça monsieursieur un peu de respect pour
les
Genson non il faut ére V musique c'est
tout s passé quoi Juli exactement ce
qu'on voit dans la vidéo il s'est passé
quoi
apr ce qui est bien c'est qu'après en
fait il y a eu quand même eu un
mouvement ouais deux ou trois
personnes hommes qui se sont vraiment
mis devant moi entre moi et l'individu
et qui l'ont empêché de de m'atteindre
d'ailleurs il y en a un qui m'a écrit
sur Twitter à l'instant ouais qui est
professeur à la Sorbonne donc on lu fait
un bisou et qui m'a dit que Queen fait
après quand quand j'ai vu repartir la
rame et que l'individu était toujours
debout en train de hurler qu'ils avaient
réussi à gérer la situation et qu'ils
ont pu reprendre leur leur chemin sans
musique alors c'était où ça contez-nous
tout ça parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un truc de fou on a l'impression que
c'est oui sur la ligne 12 que j'ai pris
hier pour me rendre pour me rendre un
rendez-vous média et et j'entre dans la
rame et en fait tout de suite elle était
blindée la rame il y avait énormément de
de monde dans la rame et tout de suite
moi j'avais des écouteurs donc pour vous
dire j'écoutis la musique assez fort
j'enlève mes écouteurs parce qu'il y a
un brois énorme dans le dans le métro
que j'entends et en fait on a un jeune
ici qui avait carrément amené son
enceinte c'était pas sur son téléphone
il avait carrément sa petite enceinte
portative pour écouter son rap ignoble à
un décibel hallucinant et son pote en
face qui parfois en rajoutait en
rajoutant de la musique par-dessus avec
son téléphone enfin c'était un scandale
quoi et en fait au bout d'un moment une
station deux stations trois stations CQ
stations et je remarque en fait en fait
un état de sousmission mais soumission
générale sidérant c'est qu'il y avait un
gamin à côté d'un des individus qui
portait une kipa d'ailleurs je je me
suis dit que dans le contexte
aujourd'hui c'était vachement courageux
mais s'il avait pu fusionner avec son
siège de métro il pour disparaître il
l'aurait fait quoi et donc il y avait ce
climat ambiant de terreur de peur de de
gêne d'exaspération mais personne disait
rien et je me suis j'ai remarqué qu'en
fait tout le monde était comme ça dans
son portable et voulait pas croiser leur
regard parce qu'en plus les mecs ils
étaient dans la ils étaient dans la
confrontation visuelle en fait ils
étaient là c'était pas simplement bon
ils ont un peu trop bu ils font un peu
trop de bruit parce qu'ils font pas
exprès non ils étaient là en mode
Conquête c'était la conquête du
territoire on est chez nous et puis
fixer bien les gens comme ça pour savoir
qui est le premier qui allait en fait
les confronter pour pour les fumer quoi
Gilles qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
sur la vidéo que Juliette est ridicule
euh d'abord se filmer quand on il a une
scène comme ça se filmer ça c'est bien
vous vous chercher en permanence le buzz
la provocation le besoin de se filmer
bien entendu je suis pas filmé moi je
suis très content qu'il y a pas eu une
agression non non mais c'est tout à fait
non mais c'est tout à fait normal je
tenais à vous le dire mais vous êtes
ridicule ils écoutai leur rap ignble
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça mais
quand il a ça dans le méro a des règles
de base vous descendez à la station
d' dis cherch à faire mme si tu dis
quand mélange un
pe ok si tu veux mais quand M c'est un
fait il y avait des mecs avec une
enceinte fais chier le monde il y avait
des mecs qui faisaient chier le monde
avec une
enceinteem usager et toi tu voudrais que
l'usager descende du métro attend un
autre métro g travaill pas descend
prévenir je vis à Paris j'ai toujours
pris l'habitude de gueuler dans le
métro
t mus
je préère les gens toujour TR que j'ai
pris j'ai eu un réflexe pour une fois cé
effectivement de filmer parce qu'en fait
si on filme pas c'est c'est une inilité
comme une are et puis et puis en fait ce
sera oublié dès demain et les gens vont
pour VI foumichel pourquoi tu donnes
toujours une prime à l'agresseur c'est
incroyable quoi tu privilégies toujours
le squatterur tu privilégies le
cambrioleur et là tu là tu privilégies
le la personne qui importe une tout le
monde en disant bah si tu es gêné tu
descends non c'est ceux qui G
vous avz
descendre ça à [__] tu vas
descendre le même principe c'est la même
chose que quand tu es cambriolé tu
appelles la police et tu attends
tranquillement que le mec vienne
t'agress fin son cambriolage c'est
exactement ça qu'il faut faire la
lo
[Musique]
journé des me qui jou
l'accordé tu sors PLA tu parles même
temps c'est insupportable arrête de
parler même temps éalement c'est
insupportable les gens qui parl en même
temps c'est non d'accord donc qu'est-ce
qu'il AC non je voulais dire que vous
avez pas compris que c'était exactement
ce genre d'inilité dont les gens ont Mar
absolument parce que c'est une forme de
terrorisme de terrorisme intellectuel
qui fait que les gens sont pétrifiés
personne ne bouge et toi en fait la
seule solution que tu vois c'est pas de
régler le problème c'est vous descendez
vous vous soumettez en
réalité V venir la police
iluse-moi tu appelles la police tu dis F
du bruit dans le métro et la police il
vont arriver
avec F du monde te fous du monde
excuse-moi elle a eu tu la traites de
ridicule elle a eu le courage d'essayer
de demander à des gens inciviles qui
sont même dans la provocation on le voit
bien de d'arrêter elle a eu un courage
et tu l' de ridicle plus de la musique
il y avait les regards insistants il y
avait le fait que dès que quelqu'un se
levait du siège d'en face le jeune
mettait ses pieds en fait sur le siège
d'en face et il y a des jeunes femmes
qui arrivaient et qui courageusement
leur demandait excusez-moi est-ce que je
peux m'asseoir il retirait ses pied
après il les fixait comme
çaéit si c'est c'est plus qu'une
incivilité les gens étaient dans la
terreur et tout le monde était malaise
dans le métro tout le monde était mal en
fait et tout le monde avait peur de leur
demander quoi que soit et d'ailleurs
quand j'ai ouvert ma bouche tout le
monde m'a défendu en fait parce que ils
attendaient que ça que quelqu'un brise
la glace en fait et perce l'absè voilà
franchement moi je vous trouve très
courageuse parce que je pense que
j'aurais pas eu
les il faut y aller quand même oser dire
on sait pas la réaction de ces gensl
aujourd'hui il y a tellement de violence
il y a tellement
d'in
C je trouve qu'en fait c'est toi qui
fait du buzz ou toi qui fais du buz
attaqu à Juliette parce qu'en fait c'est
un procès d'intention parce que ce qui
te pose un problème c'est que ce soit
elle en fait c'est elle par rapport à
ses idées par rapport à ce qu'elle peut
dire sur le plateau parfois quand elle
vient et en fait l'inciivilité c'est pas
de droite ou de gauche c'est pas extrême
droite extrême gauche c'est pas si c'est
pro ça ou anti ça en fait c'est juste
l'inivilité et ça nous concerne tous
quel que soit ce qu'on met dans notre
bulletin de vote quand on va voter et
toi ton problème à toi toi tu lui fais
un procè d'intention parce que tu fais
de la politique
t
voilà va voir tes amis sair m amis ça n'
aucun rapport non mais c'est pas une
question politique et ça pourrait être
en revanche une question de genre moi je
trouve qu'effectivement vous êtes très
courageuse parce que vous êtes une femme
de vous en prendre comme ça à des hommes
et vous avez eu beaucoup de chance il a
trois mecs qui fassent barrage et
bouclier pour vous voilà pour vous
défendre et tant mieux et bravo à ces
gens-là tu réagis comment toi dans ces
caslà en
fait non mais là là vous détournez le
truc il y a pas eu d'agression il essaie
de choper
mon
agprès il a une agression après je
ragendsies comme ça je réagis au j'ai
tout de suite condamné l'éventuelle
agression votre rencontre vrai ou fa oui
mais vous dites que je suis là pour
faire du buzz et que je suis ridicule
parce que j'ai osé dire de hommes qui
terroris un vagon entier avec leur
musique de
mer et leur regard et leurs pieds leur
façon d'être tu sais les trucs
d'intimidation dans le métro g en la
musique le r in rien à
arrêtefendrefendable on les voit les
types qui arrivent dans le métro avec
les GH blasur le Rapadonf le sourire
comme ça qui dansent et tout qui mettent
la pêche aux gens les gens adorent ça
c'est pas ça là là c'est de la
provocation c'est un moment donné c'est
du
terrorisme littér du terme se la terreur
merci Jacques mais tu parles même pas
français il un problème comprend rien il
comprend rien il com ri
é deer en fait Ava une volonté de com tu
peux dire un truc pare7% voilà merci
merci 87 % comme d'habitude voilà
comprenez-vous de cool Gueu oui à 87 %
merci Juli d'avoir été avec nous et
voilà c'est quelqu'un de de LFI qui
filme un problème
ouous
POS absolument pas
politique honnête en fait
que parce qu'elle
filme j'ai décidé de de mettre cette
vidéo en ligne c'est important parce que
rien n'est pris en compte et on se fout
de de notre de notre tête je vais être
poli et j'ai j'ai donné à votre
production Cyril la la campagne d'il y a
quelques mois de la RATP et
d'île-de-fance leur grande campagne
d'incivilité qu'ils ont fait sur les
réseaux sociaux voilà 19h3 la France
apprend que Séverine a prévu des
lasagnes ce soir pour ce soir c'est le
choc et ça c'est c'est c'est ça pour
pour la SNCF et pour l'île-de-fance
c'est ça les les incivilités dans le
métro vous voyez que ça na rien voil
vous voyez que ça n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'on vit au quotidien et en fait
personne ne prend au sérieux ce que le
le quotidien des gens et vous voyez bien
que c'est pas des femmes comme Séverine
qui parle de ses lasag qui nous pourrit
la vie au quotidien et c'est ça aussi
que jeis montré en fait dans la vidé
merci merci merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous on va passer